PUCK GOES BACK UP TYPE.
COLE FLIPS ONE
CAPTAIN.
WORKS IT TO
LAYS THE CNY.
THAT'S RED LIGHT.
COLE
196 CAREER GOALS.
TO THE
CENTER ICE WHEREW CAROLINA CONT
BACK END IS AHO.
INTO THE  ZONE.SCOTT LAUGHTON.
SMITH.
DIDN'T CONNECT THE DOTS.
PROVOROV.
PHILADELPHIA MAKES A CHAN AFTER
DIDN'T CONVERT.
>> Tripp: THEY SETTLED BACK
INTO THEIR
COUTURIER.
HE FINISHES WHAT HE STARTED.
RIGHT BACK THE OTHER WAY.
ON SITE. WHAT A NET.
AHO BUYS TIME.
SVECHNIKOV.
HE
GO ON.
THE CAPTAIN OF THE
THE CAPTAIN IS HAVING A LAUGH
H
DeANGELO.  AT THE END
OF THE SECOND PERIOD
TROCHECK DOESN'T GET THROUGH. T
SEALED IT OFF. THE OTHER SIDE.
PROVOROV.
HE CONTINUES TO MOVE UP THCANES
FACE-OFF.
WON BY CAROLINA.
A BREAK.
THAT GOES OFF OF HARPER
CAROLINA KEEPS IT IN. --ATTACKE
FAILING.
THIRD PERIOD.
TH
HITS THE POST.TOP CORNER.